[Music]
today I'm in kin by the sea so me a
proper daredevil father and son Tony and
Brandon Bailey
they run one of the largest motor stunt
teams in the country you should be aware
we go Aries he comes
[Music]
well you think Oh some right off of that
Tony yeah oh boy so where did your
passion for all things stunts come from
and I was in the Army Royal Artillery
display team and then I come out and
form be on team yeah so prop Phillipe
Bradley's got to follow him I carry on
yeah so when did you start around really
young and when you say young this
footage of me and my mum's belly
inside the arena whilst my mum was
performing during the commentaries what
makes you really want to do the stunts
it's the performance I love performing
in front of the crowd so if I was to go
out on the track and ride motocross I
enjoy it but I need a crowd watching me
that's good yeah so did you want to talk
me over any of you the kit that you've
got let me show you around we've got
loads of kit
[Music]
she's a pretty good one claw goes all
right sweet
so let me show you my baby all this
stuff's great right for me this this is
the one this is the one when I was in my
mother's belly
this is this Jeep that my old man
purchase people say get rid of it get a
new one I don't want it this is mine
I know yeah yeah I've got mates they say
that to me about my bike it's been on me
since I've had it since I started the
round it's to report it works yeah I
mean do a wheelie or two so yeah so is
this right we're gonna be going over
this ramp it's in two wheels here on two
wheels
yes yeah that's worried okay shall we
[Music]
the two wheels every day but not like
that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's this
[Music]
[Music]
the war
[Music]
that that was amazing I was about to rip
out the stakes and have a Barbie that
was unbelievable so I wanted to ask you
where do you see a business like going
in the future
this year I'm bringing in a web series
called stunted and it is based around
the team yeah just to bring it into the
modern age so a lot of people that don't
go out anymore they watch YouTube so
you're doing a YouTube show about get
out yeah that's a game I like that
that's great yeah these guys have got
testicles the size of footballs could I
do this is a job I doubt it I'm too
good-looking too risky I smashed my face
in 25 times a year but then again if I
had one of those bikes it'd make my
round a lot swifter anyway
[Applause]
you
[Music]